2かつしてきました突然のグループディスカッションコミュ障のまで地獄でした
終わりイース初回紹介してくださいあ女子です
グループディスカッション僕も不利なんですよね何か一入れ土木絶対発言とかしない
タイプの人間だったんで人々きついよね
頑張ってくださいこんにちははじめ社長ですなんかねお店に行くと売れ登ってたんで
買ってあげました
こちらバイオニックみてくださいこの無垢な彼を助けてあげるしかねぇと思ったわけ
ですよ
touch the sky 空に触れてみてくださいもともとの価格なと税込みで
17,280円
それがなど値下げされて¥6,945
半額以下まで落ちてますよどうしたマーナになった
そんなになんかヤバそうなんじゃないと思うんですけどじゃあ説明し口もなんか誰かが
小さくしたみたいについてて運営
ええええああよくわかんねーよやべやべんってなんでこんな台詞続いての中に入って
ないよってこれ英語じゃないなぁ
多分フランス語ですねし応用できます
大100m 飛ぶらしいですこの子
順次分で充電できると中でも飛ばせるし外でも飛ばせるアプリをダウンロードしろとて
つあげてみましょう
ず動いていたら卵が充電器安いんですよ女ってプレ集ですんだろうねえんなのタブ
とりあえず何カイエン多分充電しないと始まらな奴なんで卵取れず充電してみますよ
大丈夫
あなんか待ってちゃっちいタッチ会まずちゃっちくでこれ大丈夫か
5を出てきましたいや別に全然いいんですけどこれで17,000はちょっとさすがに
じゃあべ
の
僕に脱ぐ速度だけすごい速い卵の上に乗って充電できるというのはすごいですね
とりあえずアプリを行くとしますぜってーこれでもうアプリの顔見たらすぐ分かったら
かねえかソーサー結構シンプルぽいですね普通に何かこれでね押したら操作で行ってみ
たいですはい時に充電完了しましたこれ鳥さんを苦闘
これじゃあこれで食べま充電できてると思います点滅ツヤが多分10年だったんでこれ
でも待つように待つしかないですねではまず場所
神よはいだけど充電が無事完了しましたこれをスマホで操作しながら飛ばせるらしいん
ですけども僕に朝は思えませんって方が家の中でもできるというのがあり方筆順さあ
来い
あった名前を決めるんだ鳥のよしお前の名前は今日から地味だ
これでもうを操作できるのかなまずこれもできるのかぞ
ちょっとゼミ飛ばせてみますいける
ちょっと4
ちゃったんですよ
by いいですが止めませんっていうのだからもっと高度あげればいい
[音楽]
どうもないか飲んでー
さてこれこそ内緒ってこれ持ってた方がいいのかな
持ってたらと人がないかな
謝罪をしにくいの千里かよ
[音楽]
待ってくださいなんでだろーなー何か経緯があってとかないんだと思いますどこだろう
が大事にそれ
[音楽]
これはダメだ
注いきましたねちょいわけでちょっと室内だと地味飛ばなかったんで外で飛ばしてみ
ますコレットはなかったらもう終わりからいきます
います
そうはどこ行った捕まっていきます
以上
ています
はい
まあどこで狂っ
[音楽]
すみません
g 4ん
すげー
car ん
待ってな
それいなくなっちゃったん
me
uh
あっはぁ